in washington d.c this afternoon rising  tensions ahead of inauguration day  the right you see behind me on capitol  hill it's still being investigated while  law enforcement prepares for  possible violence this week a fire this  morning sent the u.s capitol into  lockdown  the secret service later said it was a  homeless camp that caught fire  but with two days to go until the  inauguration officials are working to  shore up security in the nation's  capital  nearly a dozen ex-military members have  now been arrested  in connection with the january sixth  assault on the capitol  we must police our own we must look we  can't allow people wearing in uniform  wearing q anon patches  and just let that go as their particular  political beliefs  cbs news reports federal authorities  plan to charge people associated with  radical militia groups  known to recruit military and law  enforcement members moving forward